now this is a connection with the damage
to the nordstream pipeline of course
that is the pipeline that brings gas
from Russia into Germany and then
distributed around Europe some
explosions in that pipeline that knocked
out about some 50 meters from the
pipeline this coming from the Russia
defense Ministry who are saying that
according to available information to
them
representatives of the British Navy took
part in the planning provision and
implementation of what they call a
terrorist attack in the Baltic Sea on
the 26th of September in blowing up
nordstream 1 and nordstream to gas
pipelines that coming directly from the
Russia defense Ministry that has been
translated and as we understand it other
countries have also
initiated investigations as to the
causes of that and as we understand it
the Russia defense Ministry has not
provided any evidence underpinning that
statement but making a pretty bold
accusation of British Naval involvement
in what happened to Nordstrom Pipelines